to be forlorn is to despair to be alone
without purpose these are the souls
drawn into the painting to the cold
gentle world of arendelle
some like el Frida they lost faith in
their duty and some like followers
simply outlived that Duty and others
like the Melwood Knights we'll be
talking about in this video had their
duty and their home taken from them
Melwood is a land of primitive earth
worship and its fabled nights were known
to fight hand in hand with the earth
itself this hammer for example with its
head of naturally formed stone and an
attack that rips the earth up from under
you is symbolic of that relationship in
fact their chieftain Knights who we
disturb in the painting would actually
be more accurately called
high priests many of their heavy bronze
weapons for example actually have a
modest faith requirement and they were
normally used in sacred rites not battle
upon the blades of these weapons like
the battle ax is this symbol of the
ethereal oak a sacred tree which is
clearly at the heart of their
civilization this tree appears on their
weaponry on their capes on their shields
and even their helmets are adorned with
antlers believed to grow from the
blessed beasts of the ethereal oak
judging from the horns I think that
would be a kind of stag strange right
it's a very curious tree from all
descriptions and it also appears to be a
very bountiful tree considering they cut
from it the horns for their helmets and
maybe even the wood for their shields
and I'm very confident that the ethereal
oak is actually a spirit tree as they're
described in other item descriptions for
the word ethereal can mean not of this
world and spirit trees have been
referenced multiple times to be
otherworldly the things of dreams in all
the game's spirit trees are actually
some of the kindest beings in the series
for with every new spirit tree mentioned
we learn a little bit more about them in
Dark Souls 2 for example a spirit tree
was said to have turned itself into a
shield to protect a small frightened
child in the sunken Kingdom we found one
that repairs the weapons you hit it with
and even in the undead settlement the
curse rotted great wood consumed the
curses of the town spoke at its own
sacrifice their very selfless and noble
beings considering all the sacrifices
they go through and here to the Millwood
Nights is this tree so bountiful that an
entire society was built around it
unfortunately of course according to the
mill wood armor when the fabled mill
wood forest was discovered it was a
vacant ruin the only thing left was the
ethereal oak stood rotting it said that
arranged around the rotting ethereal oak
around the basis of their civilization
were the belongings of the Millwood
Knights and they were arranged neatly on
the ground yet despite the ruin and the
rotting tree no corpses were found and I
believe the reason the description
mentions that no corpses were found is
because the Knights themselves their
being not necessarily their belongings
were drawn into the painting but we'll
get to them
so what caused this what or who caused
their forest to be brought to ruin well
we find an answer in the mill wood great
boughs which were crafted and wielded by
the Knights so that they could face
their sworn enemy this sworn enemy was
and I quote the abyss dragon and the
closest thing we have to an abyss dragon
in my opinion in souls law is the black
dragon kalameet which is an ancient
dragon that spews abyss tainted flame
and is known as the bringer of calamity
so for an abyss dragon who brought ruin
to the Millwood forest I think that
kalameet the calamitous dragon certainly
fits the bill don't you for posterity I
considered some other things I
considered the passive man because it
resembles a dragon but there are
multiple passive man and they already
have a name and it's not abyss dragon
there's also Qarth a primordial serpent
and serpents are known as imperfect
dragons and he's an imperfect dragon who
resides in the abyss however he doesn't
really fit either the Millwood Knights
created great bows to take down this
creature and you know it makes a great
degree of sense to think that they would
craft great bows to shoot down giant
flying beasts such as kalameet and this
exact thing has already happened because
it was kalameet on the receiving end of
a great arrow in another forest long ago
so this could be a sort of repeat of
that scenario in the same sense that so
many other scenarios are repeated in
Dark Souls 3
but regardless right whoever this dragon
was even if it isn't kalameet it would
seem that they're great bows they
weren't enough to take this thing down
the Millwood forest was brought to ruin
and according to their captain's ashes
the Millwood Knights lost the forest
they called home and began a journey so
long that even thoughts of their sworn
enemy washed away replaced by a vision
of a cold and brittle wood the nights
for lon were drawn into the painted
world of REM Dell and they likely found
a home to wash away the trauma of their
past and the terrible things they'd seen
a safe place at least until the
unconditional from a sink fire for Mary
under fire for hey guys thank you for
watching thank you for subscribing and
special thanks to those who support me
on patreon next week's video will be on
the core viens so I'll see you then
[Music]